hi there today we'll look at linear
transformers are secretly
fast weight memory systems by immanuel
schlag
kazuki iri and jurgen shmeduba on
a high level this paper makes a
connection between
linear transformers which are
transformers that
linearize the attention mechanism
such as the performer and fast weight
memory systems which is a bit of an
older concept
where fast weights refers to one
mechanism producing weights for another
mechanism
so like a neural network producing
weights for another neural network
the first neural network will be called
the slow weight
and the produced weights would be called
the fast weights
so the paper makes a connection between
specifically
auto regressive linearized transformers
and these fast weight memory systems and
looks at it in terms of
how much memory are they able to store
in these weight matrices and it
analyzes it and proposes a new update
mechanism for ultra aggressive
transformers
and then demonstrates kind of the the
effect of that in
experiments we'll go through the
connection they make and look at their
new
method their new proposed linearized
attention
and we'll look at the experiments and
that will be the paper
so if you like content like this please
share it out
to all your friends and enemies
because love is okay i'm becoming lex
friedman
so what are fast weight systems
fast weight systems as i already said is
when
one neural network or one mechanism
produces weights of another neural
network so
the fast network would not be learned
per se but it would
get its weights from the slow neural
network
and this here is an example of that by
the way new
new new recording setup thank you for
your feedback very much so i have
extended the screen here to cover the
entire area
please more feedback i know this is
still pixel-ish
if anyone knows how to make onenote not
do pixel-ish pdfs
please tell me all right so here is one
of these
fast weights uh mechanism so a slow net
w with slow weights continuously
generates fast weights for a fast nap
making the fast weight effectively
dependent
on the context simply put the slow that
learns to program its fast net
and here in these papers by schmidt
huberty proposes
these outer product fast mate weight
systems
and here is how it works so imagine you
have a sequential input
so x i is going to be x over time
remember we're in the auto regressive
setting so the
auto regressive setting is where we have
a sequence as inputs
and then you're from that sequence
you're trying to produce
the next element of the sequence for
example in language modeling
and then in the next steps you take that
next element
in to your context and you produce the
next next element and so on so that goes
on
and that is the autoregressive setting
so
we are wondering how do systems produce
in these other aggressive systems
produce their outputs
and one way is this fast weight system
so imagine you have these x's here which
are the input sequence so
we'll go in terms of an input sequence
how do we produce
the y uh that is
so this is the how do we produce the
next
input or specifically in a more general
setting
we have an input sequence and an output
sequence and at each step
we kind of want to produce the
corresponding output so in the first
step this
and then the second step we already have
two inputs and we produce
this output and in the third step we
have three inputs we produce
the third output sorry we have three
inputs and then the fourth step we all
have all four
we produce the fourth output of course
in the autoregressive setting we would
every time take the output and plug it
in here
at inference time not at training time
all right
so i have input sequence and output
sequence
how each how does each step look
such that we produce the corresponding
output
well here's what we do we have these
specifically
we have these matrices called w and the
w matrices
are these fast weights and you can see
the output
is simply produced by taking the current
input
and multiplying it in a linear fashion
by
the fast weight matrix okay
so right now if you just look at this
this is simply a
linear transformation the magic happens
if you consider how these weights here
come to be
so these weights are now going to
contain
the entire context of the past inside
the weights
so other than it is a bit like a
recurrent neural network where you have
a hidden state
except here the weights themselves are
the hidden state
so how do you generate the hidden the
weights here these fast weights well
these fast weights are produced
by updating the fast weights of the last
step you can
see right here and here is where the
recurrence comes in
so the fast weight of the current step
that's not supposed to happen the fast
weights of the current step
are produced by adding
on top of the fast weights of the last
step there is a non-linearity involved
right here but essentially you take the
last
fast weight and add something to it now
what is that something
that something is here this outer
product of a
and of these vectors a and b which are
themselves constructed by
taking the input and running them
through
their own neural networks or just their
own linear transformations right here
you can see that this mechanism will
continuously produce
weights so there is a few few
intricacies here
like why do this is the outer product
between the vectors
and that's needed because in every step
you want to
produce a valid weight matrix right
and this is how you produce a valid
weight matrix by taking the outer
product if now you accumulate
those outer products essentially in
these fast weights
which has some other interesting
properties and the paper is getting to
those
properties later here when it talks
about tensor product representation
theory
but essentially this is how
you how people store information
inside of matrices is a bit of magic
but imagine you have
keys and values and you want to store
those keys and values like in a database
but you want to do it
in kind of a continuous manner so this
comes from a time when people were
trying to bridge
the symbolic world to the
neural network world let's say so they
were trying to
put discrete things or objects and
symbols
into distributed representations
like vectors so if we want to build a
database
what we have to do is we're going to
have to have keys and values that we
store
right key one value one key two
value two this goes all into a database
key three value three and
if we then come and we query the
database with one of the keys
like okay i have now key two is my query
i define my query as key two and
i go to the database the database better
give me
value 2. how can we implement this as
a distributed representation database so
first of all imagine
we are going to have keys and values
they are all going to be vectors so the
keys are going to be represented as
vectors and the values are going to be
represented as vectors okay the key
maybe this this vector and this vector
here
and the values this vector this vector
and
this vector okay it's we can we can do
symbols to vectors by doing embeddings
so we know how to obtain that but now
how do we implement the database
well if i'm i'm just going to
show you what i can do how do i build
the database i'm going to build the
database as follows
i'm going to take key one and i'm going
to do the outer product
two that's that's a plus
i want to do the outer product between
key one and value one
and then i'm going to add to that the
outer product between key
two and value two and i'm going to add
to that
key three value three okay
so why why does that give us the
database
so that gives us a database and
what we want to do is we want that if
if we go to the database and we query it
with the query and this is going to be a
matrix multiplication right the database
is going to be a matrix
we want and let's say the query is key2
we want that we get value 2. it's magic
right i can just add these things to the
database with the plus and you can see i
can
also update that in the future by simply
adding to the database
one of these outdoor products and we
want
this it seems a bit like magic but
here is how it works and the condition
is that all of the keys
are orthogonal to one another if the
keys are orthogonal to one another
this is going to work because imagine we
now go to the database
and we multiply by q what does that do
that is going to be k1
we can write this as a sum right we have
this sum
over the i of
key i value outer product with
value i times
q now that we can pull in
the q so we're going to have the sum of
i
and here we're going to have the key
times the value
and this all times q
now q is going to be as we said
q is one of the keys because we query
the database with one of the keys
so here it's going to be
key number two with key i
and this is an inner product right here
and this is an
outer product with the value i now if
the keys are orthogonal
you're going to see pretty quickly that
if if
i is equal to j sorry to 2
then this is going to be just the number
one
if they are orthogonal and normalized if
the keys however are not equal so if i
is anything else than two this is going
to be zero
and magically all of the things drop
away
all of the all of the sum elements drop
away except the one
that contains v i or v2 so this is going
to get
v2 so magic
and uh as we said the conditions are
that the keys
are orthogonal to one another and and
normalized if you want but
this gives you now the flexibility if
your embeddings are
meaningful meaning that the latent space
is meaningful
you can also query your queue can be
kind of a superposition of keys or
something in between the keys and what
you'll
retrieve is an interpolation of the
values
and this is very very similar to the
attention mechanisms we have
nowadays right these queries and the
keys
and the values and this paper is going
to establish
how exactly this is similar another
similarity by the way to a tension
mechanism is exactly this
fast weight principle i've always said
that
an attention layer is essentially
a fully connected layer but the weights
aren't learned the weights are
dynamically produced by
another mechanism depending on the input
and this is exactly this fast weight
concept
so it makes total sense that there is a
connection
and it also obviously makes total sense
that someone
already invented this in the 90s as
i think that's a meme by now right so
how do we make the connection
between a tension mechanism and these
fast weight
modules so here's how we do it
first this is the attention mechanism as
we know it it's just
written a bit differently in the
specific context
of auto regressive transformers or auto
regressive attention mechanisms
so we don't care about how we do all the
queries keys and values
we care about how do we produce the
queries keys and
values of the very last step because in
autoregressive transformers
what you have as a limitation is this
causal attention
so if you have your sequence and
in a self attention or in a let's say
non-autoregressive
setting you would have attention from
each element to each element so all the
queries can attend to
all the keys however in a
causal attention layer let's just build
a causal attention layer on top here of
the
non-causal attention which makes
absolutely no sense but
every single query can only attend
to keys that are in the past so this can
attend
to here and here and i'm
i'm drawing the arrows in a different
direction but you see what i mean
you can only attend to things that are
in the past
and technically that is not
technically it is not it is too much of
a constraint
because if you have multiple layers and
you think of
what is what does it mean to be
auto-aggressive what it means to be
auto-aggressive
is that you want to produce the next
element
so if you have a stack of layers you
want to produce this element
right here it is perfectly conceivable
that the information in your network can
flow from this element which is maybe
the
the noun in the sentence to the verb
of the sentence here to the subject of
the sentence
here and then to the front again or
to here again as long as you don't draw
information
from from over here from the future
you're good right
but technically within one context
window
it is technically allowed to send
information around like this now
the problem with this is we can't easily
parallelizably train
things like this so what we do is we
simply restrict
in each layer the attention to only
attend to things in the past which means
that we end up
with kind of these these attention
sort of like a cones where you can only
send information
forward and not backward even within a
layer even
though it's technically allowed so this
restriction
is also encapsulated in this formulation
so we're going to
ask ourselves how do we produce the
current
output y i the current output is going
to be produced
by simply looking at the current query
because all the past queries we've
already computed in the last steps right
so we simply need the current query and
but we need
all the values and all the keys right
the v and the k
being capital here means that they are
the accumulation of everything in the
past
this is exactly what we said you can in
fact attend
to your own to all the past but
not the future so the current output is
going to be produced
by the current query attending to all of
the past
the past here is constructed you can see
in each time step
what we're going to do is we're going to
compute the current key and value
and we're going to concatenate that with
the past keys and values that we've
already computed
there's no need to compute things twice
here so
that's you know in each time step we
simply need to compute the current
uh queries keys and values and the keys
and values we're going to accumulate
into these
matrices by concatenating them now
if we slide usually this extends the
sequence like this right we extend and
extend
and extend and extend transformers have
a limited size window
so eventually these things here are
going to drop away
in which case these matrices here are
going to
not be concatenated but kind of shifted
towards the right
but you know that's that is a minor
detail and the queries keys and values
are simply going to be produced by the
learned matrices here like this is so
this is
very standard transformer or
very standard attention mechanism
okay now they say look here so here we
have the softmax
and the softmax is pretty intrinsic to
the attention
mechanism because otherwise it would
just be a linear transformation
so the softmax what the softmax is going
to do once
the query attends to all the keys
once the query attends to all the keys
we're going to normalize that
using a softmax which basically gives
you a distribution
over the over the input
sequence so you don't want to know
where should i you want to know where
should i attend in proportion to
everywhere else so there's a
normalization involved
and of course also the non-linearity and
the softmax but the real bottleneck
is the normalization so first they say
what happens if we just leave away
the softmax and this is this is a
rederivation from other papers by the
way this is
they're just building their case here so
what happens if we leave away the soft
max
if we leave away the softmax we simply
have here
is the key query here is the attention
and that is going to be multiplied by
the values
now we can rewrite this a bit actually
it comes from here that's
here here is the here is the tension
matrix this is the attention matrix for
the current time step i
right just for the last query
and that's going to be multiplied by the
values and that gives you your output
so the attention matrix tells you how
you need to aggregate the values tells
it tell you
what the value of the things you
aggregate or
and you do a weighted accumulation
it gives you your output if you rewrite
this a little bit
you can clearly see that instead of an
inner product between the keys
and the queries then being multiplied by
the values
you can as well write this as an outer
product between the values and the
keys and then a multiplication by the
query
and this should you know be familiar to
you by now
so here you can write this as an outer
product
of the individual keys and values of the
past
and then the queries and this here is
exactly this database we talked about
actually with the sum including the sum
so this is the database
of the past and now you can see the
connection to these to these
uh fast weight algorithms i mean it's
it looks exactly the same except it has
the fast weight also had this kind of
sigmoid in it
but essentially you're building this
matrix
this so the matrix is going to be
multiplied not by
x directly but by q which is a linear
transformation of x
so that's pretty similar this is this is
what they call w
w i and
your output is simply going to be a
linear function
of the input so to say and it is also
going to be
a query into this distributed database
so they say
we can further rewrite these equations
such that they directly relate to
these fast weight equations so
you can build this up step by step
instead of building the whole sum
what you can do is you can simply write
this wi here
as a decomposition
into the wi from the last step simply
add
the current outer product to it between
values and keys
and then you have your current fast
weights your current database that you
then
query by q so this
relates it to the fast weight algorithm
now we made a crucial step in that
we left away the soft max right and that
now we're going to have to fix that so
this has already
been done like we've already come this
far and i've made a video about the
per former so the performer
reaches this point and then they say
okay
now instead of leaving away the soft max
we can generalize
we can generalize the softmax by writing
it as a sort of kernel
by writing the softmax explicitly
equation 7
can be written as so this is the full
equation equation 7 is the full
with the softmax attention can be
written as this
and this is a bit tricky so k is the cur
is a kernel and the kernel
in this case is the exponential function
the soft max is going to be this part
right here so it involves this and is
going to be
normalized right the soft max has the
exponential function
and it has the normalization so this is
going to be
the soft max part and then simply
multiplied by
the values over here and
aggregated okay
so you can write it as such and then you
can think
about okay what
kind of kernel could we substitute
to approximate the softmax but
without having you know kind of the
pesky non-linear
things so if you know anything about
kernels which i don't but there is a
good street talk
episode which i'll link where we where i
got to ask all the dumb
questions about kernels i hope that
helps but
every kernel represents an inner product
in some kind of in some kind of
space so every kernel can be implicitly
written
or explicitly written as this inner
product
in some kind of space and phi here is
the function that
maps you to that space and the performer
thought can we find so the performer
explicitly showed
which phi you have to choose in order
such that if you plug it in to this
kernel
it gives you back the soft max
and that turned out to be an infinitely
large space
so an in like a non-computable function
but then they ask themselves can we
substitute
can we approximate that kernel with a
finite
function phi right here and that is the
performer paper is very
theoretically grounded but it has some
problems and they discuss the problems
here but first see if you write the
kernel
as such an inner product and which you
could actually compute
you can then you can see here
this bracket is the problem this
and this since the kernel is non-linear
you cannot just pull these things apart
however if you write the kernel as the
inner product if you know what the phi
is you can write it as such and pull it
apart
and then you can do the same
transformations as here so you can see
that here it's an inner product
but if this is linear you can also see
this as first
the outer product of the key mapped
through the file function
with the value so there's an outer
product and only then
multiplied by the query and you can as
well see the normalization
as an accumulation of these keys
and only then you multiply the query
in here so this gives you the benefit
that
in not in each step you have to compute
these things in fact
you can accumulate these things across
the time steps
they make this explicit here write it as
an explicit outer product
you can see it is the same thing again
where
you can build this database from the
past so it's not
value times key but its value times
phi of the key and for the normalization
you can equally build up
this this accumulator on the bottom
right here so that's going to be your z
variable you can see that this pretty
much results in the same algorithm
except that we also keep track of the
normalization here
which we can do just as we build the
fast weights we can accumulate the
normalization
i believe this was already also
discussed in the performer paper but
it's pretty cool to see here
that everything leads to the same path
so
first we went from fast weights then we
looked at
transformers without the softmax and we
said oh
if this is linear then there is a clear
connection to fast weights
and now we say okay if it's not linear
but if the kernel if we can find an
explicit kernel
then we can write it as a linearly
decomposable thing and then it's also
a fast weight algorithm modulo
denormalization
down here which i guess would still
count as a fast
weight a fast weight algorithm
so they say essentially these linear
transformers are fast weight algorithms
is specifically in the autoregressive
case right always think
that this is in the autoregressive case
because the specific
constraint of how we train other
regressive models with the causal
attention mask gives rise to being able
to write the algorithm
like they do here so they discuss
this um capacity limitation now
while the softmax is super non-linear
and and
normalizes and all of that it
sort of has is not subject to these
capacity limitations but
it is subject to other capacity
limitations but if this is
linear um if this is now a linear
algorithm
they say endlessly adding new
associations to a memory that's the
database of finite size and is in
equation 17
inevitably will reach a limit in linear
tension information is stored in a
matrix and is retrieved using matrix
multiplication
as a consequence to prevent associations
from interfering with each other upon
retrieval
their respective keys need to be
orthogonal
otherwise the dot product will attend to
more than one key and return a linear
combination
of values with keys embedded in a d
dot space d dot here is the that's the
in
the space of the inner product
there cannot be more than the dot
orthogonal vectors that is storing more
than the dot associations
will result in a retrieval error in
linear transformers
when the length of the sequence is
longer than the dot the model might be
in such an over capacity regime so now
they
say since these linear transformers
are all fast weight algorithms are
they have these capacity limitations
right they they build this linear
database with outer products
so technically they can only store a
finite and finite given by the
dimensionality amount
of distinct data points now
this is a very special way of looking at
these things
and we're going to see
later what they do so in their
experiments i can tell you right now in
their experiments what they do is they
have
a sequence of random keys
together with constructed
constructed values so the values are
kind of orthogonal
unit vectors but the keys the keys
have to be learned but they are
so let them be fixed set of keys sorry
not the keys have to be learned the
embeddings have to be learned
let them be finite and fixed sets of
keys and values
okay and they are sampled randomly
so they're going to produce key value
pairs
randomly with random keys and fixed
values and they
see whether or not they can store and
then retrieve an arbitrary one
from that database q is randomly chosen
to be one of the l
keys so we store l
elements that we sample at random and
then we see can we retrieve
one of them now this isn't
this isn't exactly what we want in
transform this is a very special way
it's a very computational way of looking
at things like okay what's the memory
capacity here how many distinct things
can we store
what we want in transformers is more
we're not interested in
storing everything accurately but
i think we explicitly want this
interpolation in transformers
it is very useful to look at these
mechanisms from
this kind of synthetic setting where we
really test the memory capacity but it's
important to keep in mind
that that is not ultimately what we want
ultimately we explicitly want those
superpositions to occur
because in nlp we have synonyms like we
have
same information from different words we
have words in between
other words and so on so it is not
exactly
you know the criticism here is valid but
it is not exactly on
in you know in the wound of what's
hurting in transformers
nevertheless um they say can we
improve can we improve this update rule
they say linear transformers can end up
in this
over capacity regime where they need to
store
more things than their dimensionality
allows
if the sequence length l exceeds the
dimension
of the keys once
an in over capacity an ideal memory
model should dynamically interact with
the memory contents and selectively
determine
which associations to remember and to
forget
so they criticize transformers here in
saying
with this update rule where we only ever
we only ever concatenate
right we have the key and we concatenate
the new key right here and so on
now irrespective of whether we limit the
sequence length right here if the
sequence and you know we drop things
here
if the sequence length we consider is
higher than the dimensionality
we're bound to have keys that conflict
with each other and so they say
when you add a new key you know given
that you are bound to override each
other
you should be able to sort of
dynamically
dynamically add keys and not only
concatenate to a fixed
set now what they're going to do is
actually not
change the keys but they're going to
change the values
and this is you know something i quite
find pretty cool because they also
you also concatenate the value onto this
but what they're going to say
is that instead of just appending the
keys and the values
what we're going to do is since this key
is going to conflict with one key that's
in here
at least let's say it's going to
conflict with one key
what we're going to do is we're simply
going we're not going to store the
actual
value to this key we're going to store
the diff
in value between this key
and the key that it's conflicting with
you know maybe they're not fully
overlapping
maybe this key is a little bit off that
key but mostly
so you know if we enter this key and we
would just store naively the value
we would also retrieve the value
associated with the other key because we
overlap and then we'd get like a
superposition of the two values and so
on
so what we should do is instead of
storing the value we should store the
diff
between the value the old value
and the new value and then when we
retrieve and inevitably overlap
we're going to retrieve right we're
going to retrieve the old value
and we're going to retrieve the new
value but now that's the diff
so plus okay
other way around so we're going to store
this plus
v and since we store the diff this
cancels out
and we only have the new value that's
pretty
cool um yeah so
instead of actually storing the diff
they say
you know the network should be able to
say how much it wants to update that
value
so the network is going to also output a
number
beta that is as you can see or computed
from the input
by a little one layer neural network and
what you're going to do is you're going
to first retrieve the value
that is associated with the key that you
want to put in
so this this value here is
that's the old value because this key
probably overlaps with something so
you're going to use that key
as a query into the database retrieve
the value that's associated before
then you're going to interpolate
the old value and the new value and
that's what you're going to
store and that turns out to be
like this so you generate the new
database from the old database
plus here the diff that's the diff
between the values weighted by a factor
saying how much really you want to
update that because of course
also when you input the old key
you're going to retrieve the new value
so
you might be you know you might
not want to just slam in the new value
because of course the old value isn't
updated
yet so you know this this gives you sort
of a handle on that
all right and then
of course you'd simply retrieve the new
thing
with the query and now if the query is a
key
that's overlapping you're going to
retrieve the old value and you're going
to retrieve
this weighted update on top of that
very cool they also discuss different
normalization strategies so one
normalization
strategy because we we also have this
denominator
in the soft max right and if they simply
do these accumulations as we saw on top
right if they simply compute this
and they compute this using
the accumulation techn like an
accumulators they
are bound to sort of explode because
also these kernels they map things to
positive space
so things explode so what they say is we
should
change our phi here to
be the phi divided by just sort of the
sum of the entries so this is an easy
normalization you can do independent of
anything else and it keeps the values in
check
the last thing they do is they now
suggest
a they suggest a fi
so you know given that they've
criticized
uh things they say okay let's look at
the phi's that are already around
that would meet our requirements so
we're looking for
a function that acts as a
mapping to the space of inner products
that is going to replace the kernel
so one suggestion here is to use elu
plus one which is fairly easy
but it has some disadvantages namely
importantly as a
as an element-wise function preserves
the dimension of the input key vector
without modifying the memory capacity as
discussed so this
not only is this not the soft max it
also doesn't
you know is is actually problematic
because
it you have no handle on the memory
capacity the reasoning here is that
if you want to go from non-linear
with you know technically infinite
capacity or
whatever non-linear bound if you want to
go to
linear which has a clear upper bound on
the capacity
you need to have kind of a hyper
parameter where you can
artificially increase that capacity to
make up for the fact that you're going
to linear space
this doesn't have it even though it's
super easy
on the other hand favorite plus which is
the algorithm from the performer
has that but it relies on kind of random
sampling from a normal distribution
and it also relies on kind of
complicate it's not super complicated
but it is
mathematically actually rigorous if you
go into enough dimensions you will
accurately approximate
the soft max but you need
random features for that and these
random features
can you know either hurt your
performance it can hurt your performance
if you happen to sample them
in a bad way and you sample them once
per training run which or per model
which so you don't have do-overs in that
i guess you can train again but
you know so they suggest a thing that is
easy
and you have a handle on the
dimensionality so they say
we consider four different keys
right if we have four different keys in
r2
they are going to so the keys are in two
dimensions
what they're going to do is they're
going to construct a mapping into
four dimensions such that they have the
highest
possible chance of if two keys
are different they're going to be
orthogonal to each other in that higher
space
now they're going to do this as this so
these are the four dimensions of the
mapping
these are this this is going to be a
vector at the end of these five
functions
and the r is relu so
what they're going to do if they they're
going to take a key
and they're going to multiply simply the
positive part
of the dimensions the negative parts and
the cross parts right here to get the
four features
which means that a given key can only be
non-zero in one of those four things
right like either
either your first coordinate is positive
or negative or your second coordinate is
also positive or negative that gives you
four possibilities
and the construction here makes it such
that only one of those
four entries is non-zero depending on
which
section you are you can see that right
here
these are the four sections so if your
vector is right here
it's going to be non-zero in the blue
component but
not in the green orange or purple
components
so they say this gives you kind of
maximal if two
if two keys are in the same quadrant yes
they're going to overlap
in that higher dimensional space but if
two keys are in different quadrants
they're going to be
guaranteed orthogonal they extend this
to here so they're going to say we're
going to choose this parameter
new here which that is going to be the
handle on our dimensionality
so nu is going setting new
is is upgrading your dimensionality of
the mapping if new
is equal to one you keep the
dimensionality of your
key actually you you double it um but
you can set it to two or actually they
only ever go
to three three is as high as they go
so they make the intrinsic dimension
three times higher than the original
dimension at maximum so what are they
going to do
they're simply going to take the vector
here of positive and negative elements
of your key
and they're going to ch so for entry i
they're going to choose
the entry i and they're going to
multiply that with again the the relu
of some other coordinate of the same key
so you're simply taking two coordinates
take the relu of them
you multiply them together if you
include the negative parts of the vector
that gives you exactly what we've seen
up here
and the new gives you saying like
how many different coordinates do you
want to multiply so
if new is one you simply multiply
coordinates one
and two and then two and three and then
three and four
four and five and so on until you once
around
if you if nu is two you do all of that
but
also you concatenate that with
one and three two and four three
and five and so on now
at the end they wrap around like the
last one would be like
10 and 1.
they say they have code for this it's
pretty easy you simply kind of roll
around
the the vector and then rayleigh it and
then multiply it
or the first relu first concatenate the
positive and negative parts relu that
and roll and then multiply
they say this gives you in this upper
dimension two
times the dimensionality of the key
two because you have the positive and
negative elements times the
dimensionality of the key times
new now this only works uh actually so
this is wrong i believe this is wrong
right here here they say you can choose
new
to be any of these values which is
not correct because if new
is higher than i believe d
what's d key 2 divided by 2. so if it's
higher than d
key then you're going to have duplicate
elements because you sort
if you consider this here and you view
it as a matrix that you later
unroll right as the projection up you
have
i and you have i sorry you have nu here
and what you can have is at maximum
sorry this is i plus nu
right you can have i attending you can
have one attending to two
you can have one attending to two and
three
you can have one attending to two three
and four
but at some point if you know uh
and then you have to have two attending
two
so you can have one attending to this
this this this this this
two cannot attend to two but it can
attend to three
four five or a ten two it can be
multiplied
with this three can be multiplied
by four five six and so on and since you
roll around
what their code actually rolls around so
it goes around here
you can easily see that
now if new
is equal to the full 2 minus 1 to the
full dimensionality
of the matrix here then this element is
going to be the same as this element
because it's going to be
the first one is going to be k1 and k2
and then
in the second one because you roll
around it's going to be k2
and k1 which is going to be the same
so just a little mistake in how you can
choose nevertheless they never get up
there
they go one two or three and
they never even get close to that being
a problem all right so i've already told
you the experiments they do
where they try to retrieve random values
and i've already tried what kind of
problem i have with that nevertheless
they show here that the linear and i'm
sorry this is super pixel-ish i'm going
to try to fix that
in the future the linear transformer as
you can see
it has a
so here is the number of unique keys
that you can store
the lower your curve the better so these
are the mistakes this this is the loss
that you make
so the linear one the dimensionality is
64 the of the of the
keys so you would expect that it can
store
up to 64 keys well
and then it can't store more it gets
conflicts
and that's exactly what you see so here
you start off
no loss and then at around 60 the loss
shoots up because you get into conflicts
interestingly this favor the performer
algorithm
shoots up immediately and that's you
know probably because it's not
built for this specific purpose
they try it with quite a high number of
random features
but it is pretty interesting to see
whereas
their method so if they choose new
equals to 1
it goes for double which you would
exactly expect so if new is equal to one
the dimensionality of their algorithm is
two times the dimensionality of the keys
uh so after 120 some if the
loss shoots up if you choose new to be
2 then after wait
then after you can see right here after
240 some
you shoot up and if you choose new
equals to 3 after
306 while the soft max
it gets you know it gets into the error
rates here but this
is a different regime of bounds we
cannot analyze this with the
linear bounds we derive because this is
the highly
highly non-linear highly infinite
dimensional implicitly soft max
this is pretty cool as i said even
though it's it's not
exactly what we want from our attention
mechanisms
but it's cool to look at them in this
way they do a bunch of other experiments
and they
actually do language modeling so they do
machine translation
and machine translation it's not
it's not really an auto regressive
problem per se i mean it is
in but you always have the input
sentence and then
you have the output sentence and only
the output sentence
is auto regressive and not the input
sentence
but still you can actually formulate it
as an auto regressive
uh problem and if you only do causal
attention in this part i don't know how
much that hurts you but
technically you don't need to the
original transformer i think
didn't do that it did full attention in
the input and then
causal attention in the output so here
they show that in the intermediate
dimensions
they outperform the performer but if you
go to higher dimensions the performer
outperforms them
however in language model experiment so
this is perplexity so lower is better
in language model experiment um
no sorry they they here they compare
update rules uh
like they compare update rules plugging
it in
into the different transformers so they
show that their update rule
is better than just the sum update rule
in the linear transformer
and in the in the performer
so here you can see the number of
trainable parameters
in our update rule respectively for the
small and medium configurations
so interestingly enough
also there's yet more evidence that you
might not need
position encodings if
you have an autoregressive models which
is quite astonishing but if it's
autoregressive i can sort of understand
it because it kind of
acts like an rnn and an rnn can
intrinsically
build a counter in the um
they build a counter in
inside the update mechanism so
i don't want to go too much into the
experiments right here you can look at
them
they are let's say they're promising in
terms of
real applications and it's definitely
worth checking
this out uh if you are in another
regressive problems
though where it really shines is where
you
really have kind of a sequential task
and need to remember
symbolic information might not
necessarily be
super applicable to language that has
it's not really distinct symbols right
there is interpolations and so on so
that would be my comments on this paper
video is already too long
thank you very much for listening i'll
see you next time